hello and welcome to GameSpot after dark
episode 48 this is game sports official
video game podcast
I'm your host filling in for Jake who's
taking a break I'm Callie claggy and I'm
joined by John Luke psyche what up
Michael hi um what I do and a very
special guest today Steve Saylor the
blind gamer and media editor at can't I
play that hello thanks so much for
having me
well good we're so excited to have you
on the show today hmm
oh there's absolute all my I'm I've been
excited to talk with you all about a ton
of stuff and of course probably the last
of us which I am very excited to talk
about as well it's gonna be a fun one
one of the more fun discussions of the
Last of Us good you could say the
discussion I'm interested in having a
blast you know it is quite the discourse
see game but we're gonna have a good
time today Before we jump into what
we've been playing we always do this I
don't know if you've heard of our famous
segment here the Chris from Dayton Ohio
I'm not gonna do the song this time
because I'm enjoying it and it just the
dynamic just doesn't work there however
this is the segment that everybody knows
and loves where we ask you who the hell
are you well okay well I'm Steve Saylor
I'm an commonly known as a blind gamer
I'm an accessibility advocate and
consultant I've worked with several
studios including Ubisoft EA and most
recently Naughty Dog on the Last of Us
part two
I am a media editor at can I play calm
which is an accessibility focused
website where we do video game reviews
from an accessibility standpoint and
yeah and also I am now kind of sort of
known as the guy who cried on the
internet about accessibility settings
and last was too and yeah that's
business real expiry
it's a wonderful thing to do and for all
the things to be known for on the
Internet that's all my favorite ones if
people know me it's I'm a big fan of
crying so shout-out to you Steve we here
we saw we love to cry part of the
Christmas Dayton Ohio segment is like
what kind of games do you like are there
like games that you always go back to
that kind of thing
gaming background stuff just so people
get to know you a little bit better uh
well for me my gaming background is kind
of a bit weird and mixed I grew up
mainly as a casual gamer at best and
mainly because actually it from a sex
accessibility standpoint I just I always
thought like I just sucked at video
games I would watch my brother play them
more often than I would play them myself
but the games I was able to play and
enjoy mostly are a lot of sort of the
franchise type games so anything from
like Star Wars Star Trek The Matrix even
like it yeah like any of those kind of
games I think probably though some of my
favorite games of all time
I mean The Last of Us 2 is now up there
Red Dead Redemption and red ever attempt
Shinto and let you sell the breath of
the wild and and that kind of sums up a
lot of sort of what I enjoy the most
which is something that's very a heavy
and story based and just like something
I can just sort of sink my teeth into
without it being super huge and
open-world because sometimes those can
scare me aka Skyrim but yeah so that's
kind of that's kind of my gaming
background and I've only just been kind
of really getting into hard like
hardcore into the gaming side since 2015
since starting my youtube channel where
I started playing video games for just
kind of entertain my friends and
basically been saying for years
hey I suck at video games here's proof
and it was just the great way to be able
to that and then eventually over time I
kind of
got into the accessibility side and I've
been an advocate ever since so I'm
always on the lookout for Bazin games
and yeah it that's that's a lot of it
kind of summed up in a nutshell but yeah
that's my gaming background that's
awesome um I so breath of the wild and
Red Dead Redemption to are kind of
linked in my mind cuz of like how you
just kind of go where your heart takes
you and follow the weird incidental
story things that happen so I see the
pattern there for sure but I forget what
I was gonna say I just I don't know I
know what I was gonna say I know I was
gonna say I think getting into like
covering an aspect of games really
changes your relationship with them and
I was gonna ask if like you feel like
your experience with gaming has changed
since you've gotten into that
accessibility advocacy because you know
you can tell like it meant so much to
you I mean everybody could see that but
the Last of Us part to do you think
covering it has something to do with
that or just because you've played a lot
of games in your life right mm-hmm
yeah I would say it's it definitely has
changed sort of my relationship with
games kind of a quick story like I said
I always thought that I just sucked at
games and and it was more like on my
youtube channel used to say like it was
more funny to watch me fail than it is
for me to actually do well and it was it
wasn't until I was invited to be a
panelist at a UX summit that was put on
by Ubisoft in Toronto and they had
developers from all around the world
kind of come up and and learn from other
developers about UI UX and they kind of
dedicated a whole day to accessibility
and I had always seemed like heard of
accessibility at that point and I was
like oh that's cool but I was more
thinking of it from my perspective I was
like oh I'm the only gamer here that's
on a panel a rest of all that just
developers and I was I felt like I was
kind of represented
the gamers - the people that get to make
our favorite games and it wasn't until I
was on stage in the middle of the panel
and I had Brice Johnson who is the
accessibility tech lead for Microsoft
who helped go invent the adaptive
controller and then I had Alex and the
Aniki concept artist on last was - at
Naughty Dog and she was also a large
response for the accessibility charted
for sitting there it was like it was
actually in that moment in like I think
there's video proof of this you can able
to see kind of that in this particular
moment when I realized it was like okay
I've been telling myself that for years
I sucked at games but it was that game
sucked for me and it was at that moment
forward that accessibility kind of
became basically just how I felt like
what I focused on it allowed me to sort
of take a look at games from from that
sort of critical eye and more different
than and then sort of just reviewing a
game on the story and gameplay which I
still do and I and I loved and I loved
discussing all of that stuff but being
able to see kind of the the nuts and
bolts and the concepts of accessibility
was was really interesting to me and
definitely changed the way I sort of saw
games like for instance The Witcher 3 I
know how much of a huge like game that
is for people and it's some people's
favorite game of all time and I was so
frustrated by it because of the lack of
accessibility options and and I know
that's ironic because I'm wearing a
cyber fun which I do hope that was
cyberpunk that they kind of changed the
way they sort of look at accessibility
but the text was so small on that screen
that I'd literally was inches away from
my TV and I still could barely read than
the the menus that were in that and same
with legends a Link to the Past I have
never played up that before
up until literally last year I thought
it was like kind of like when like it
was one of those games that just sort of
passed me by and I know how great and
how
that is and again it's like on like the
top lists of some of the best games of
all time but I grew frustrated with it
because it just wasn't accessible for me
and I actually had to stop halfway
through because I couldn't play any
further and that like that to me was it
was frustrating but it also made me more
focused on like okay I want to make sure
that like kids growing up today that are
disabled whether you have a visual
impairment you're deaf or
hard-of-hearing or you have a motor
disability I want to make sure that the
games that that those kids are gonna be
able to play aren't going to be
accessible to them so they don't have to
have that frustration and that to me
Spurs me on as anytime I get frustrated
over options that are like sensibility
options that are not in the games but
and I get to celebrate the successes
much like The Last of Us doesn't
wonderful um thank you for sharing back
because I think I think a lot of people
can relate to that I think you know
there's there's lots of things about
gaming that in the past have been
barriers for lots of different kinds of
people to get into them right so it's
it's not always about accessibility but
I think a lot of people and a lot of our
listeners can really relate to that so
we'll talk about that more in depth with
philosophers specifically I just want to
call out you spitting bars when you said
was it I when you realize that you
didn't suck at games games suck for you
and I was like that's balls right there
because like yeah I just saying that I'm
like that clicks for me I'm like yes I
see exactly what you're trying to get at
and I hope you know folks like you have
really because for us we take games like
we we play them and we take them for
granted in many ways because we can
interact with them on on that level but
it's easy for us to forget about like
okay there are small things that can
break a game for someone who might need
that little extra help to just get past
or anything like text like of course an
RPG you need to read text to advance but
if it's illegible
and it breaks the entire game and that's
that's unfortunate so I'm really glad
like these conversations are becoming
normalized and that's that's really cool
man yeah and and I totally agree and and
I and I get it too like it's not I'm
never upset at anybody who just sort of
doesn't think of these sort of things or
even developers when they're not sort of
think about it when they're in
development because I get it like it's
something that doesn't necessarily touch
on an aspect of life whether they either
don't have a disability themselves or
they don't know anyone that has a
disability so that never seems that will
always come top of mind but that's why
there are advocates like myself that are
speaking up about it and basically
letting developers like it's okay we get
it you know about it now and let's let's
let's even build the work together to be
at least be able to create something
because we always say like even when I'm
consulting with studios it's like it's
okay to start small and build up from
there for future projects because you
learn as you go and we're not expecting
every game to be on a percent perfectly
accessible out of the gate even the last
of us to it started with the
accessibility that they brought in on
uncharted 4 and a few of the things that
they even added in as features that
weren't necessarily built for
accessibility in uncharted 4 became a
staple accessibility feature and the
Last of Us and we'll talk about that in
a bit but like it started from there and
because of the what they learned from it
Naughty Dog was basically able to take
last of us too and just sort of like ok
let's start let's start from lesser from
beginning and let's run with it and see
and see how far we can go yeah and the
more that happens the more games are
gonna have those kinds of features but
yeah we will talk about that in a second
that's a nice little teaser yeah first
we of course have to talk about what
we've been playing lately that isn't the
last of us I guess let's start with you
John Luke uh well some that isn't last
of us actually can't watch about you or
watch well so Jake's not here so I mean
let's just get ready to an anime
hey I'm watching Death Note again I just
did that to me my girlfriend I've been
like just finding new stuff and I was
like we were like going through like the
list of everything that like you know we
were like that we loved before we met
each other and like alright so it's like
you know be watchful metal we didn't
want you know played persona 4 and all
this stuff and we're going through it
and we're kind of getting to the end of
the list and one of them was death note
for me that I had seen
she tried watching the first episode a
while back and hated it and then and
we're like ok I was like ok that's it's
fair and but then for whatever reason we
were just like yeah let's give it
another try
so we watch like first up something we
watch the second episode and by the
second episode she's like I love this
show giorgia show I can't believe I know
first episode it has a girl in it oh she
loves me
yeah she's she's amazing she's like
absolutely George's kind of kind of girl
yeah my mom hates everyone hates me my
brother and I forced my mom to watch
Death Note like a couple of weeks ago
she's her perfect foil for light like
you have these two these two
intellectual men who are like battling
it out and then me so just comes in and
just [ __ ] everything up stupid and
you're like I love you that show is
fantastic lights got mad in sulphides
the language playing it now like
watching it now after like seeing what
the Internet has to offer
he's like totally recontextualize effort
has recontextualized light in a real
real no good way not that he was ever
good but different it hit different I
don't know I just love that show still
like I think um like the battle of wits
between between care and our is it's so
it's so good it's so god what a good I
mean
it's I love that the animation is like
kind of [ __ ] too like yeah that's like
it has such good mid-2000s vibes yeah
the I know it's like I'll say cuz part
of its fair like from the manga but like
Ryu clike his face just never changes at
all it's like that bug guys my favorite
my favorite shot I've big camilo anime
is when light knows up there security
cameras it is in his house so he's like
pretending to act casual so he buys like
a like a porn magazine and he's just
like looking at like pinups of girls and
it's just this shot of him looking and
then reuse over his shoulder and his
eyes are just bulging out caring right
most good [ __ ] is good I'm really
enjoying watching it I was I was like a
little worried I was like maybe I won't
enjoy it as much the second time joke
even better good
alright we're gonna keep the anime train
rolling Michael oof i'ma try and get
through I realized when I listen back to
episodes I usually take up the most time
to talk about who's hitting me up on
disk or okay and everyone I usually take
the most amount of time to talk about
gains but I'm gonna try and get through
these fast I actually don't have that
much to say about some of the things
I've been playing I'll start will to
continue the enemy train I guess it's
all about C no Alice which just came out
today Wednesday it's the new Yoko taro
game and it's a mobile RPG with gotcha
elements and all that it's it's pretty
dope because it with it this being a a
mobile RPG it's kind of like the the
expectations for storytelling are like
they're pretty low so yo Katara's but
like [ __ ] it I'm a goal like balls to
the wall wildest [ __ ] and he basically
takes fairy tale characters like Alice
Little Red Riding Hood and characters
like that from story from books and
fairy tales and it turns them into
badass anime girls like Alice in
Wonderland
yeah like Alice in Wonderland Alice
alright it's like the super dark and
disturbing story it's kind of cryptic
too and then you've it's
it's got some really good artwork and
it's got some it's got some really good
music because the Soyo Kotaro is the
creative director and the composer for
this game is the same composer as Nier
automata so it's like this music is I
don't want to say all this music is too
good for a mobile game but in a way I'm
like if you put this soundtrack over a
epic battle in your automata it would be
like [ __ ] perfect fit that's how good
this music is in this mobile RPG but
it's fun like I'm actually not too
familiar with how like schemes such as
fake rant order work or granblue fantasy
the mobile RPGs so I'm having a little
bit trouble like getting my head around
how all these mechanics work I'm sure
people look at this but ok yeah we were
we know how this works but for me I'm
like what is a lot of menu stuff but I
don't know it's free-to-play it's mobile
game check it out it's typical gotcha
like where you're like collecting
different characters and they have like
the different stats kind of stuff yeah
well it's it's more of the weapons that
are kind of like the gotcha things so
it's like weapons are also spells and
then you have different tiers and then
you're supposed to roll with whatever
like yeah chess and then you got the
different types of weapons that ate it
for me yeah it actually is it's quite
complicated edgy fantasy girls yes man
you lost me at it's really complicated
I'm guessing this game doesn't do it but
I'm I'm just thinking about the idea of
like what Yoko taro could do with like a
game that's like a has like
microtransactions in it and like the
kind of [ __ ] he could get up yeah I
have your mom's credit card and pay in
order to like keep your other characters
games alive my credit card I have I have
an interview with it or I did an
interview with them in the lead up I'm
still working on a story but I asked him
about how he feels about monetization
and how you gonna continue the story
because this is an ongoing game he says
I think the story will continue for as
long as sales continue human greed is
never-ending isn't it
and and also assets [ __ ] but he's more
like you as long as this is around I'm
gonna be complicit and you know what I
get it
and also I asked him like has things
changed for him since Nier automata and
he's always like oh or he said that
quotes I've always been stubborn but
once automata became a hit everyone
began to say yes to my stubborn demands
everyone may think that I became
arrogant because I made a hit and got
carried away I'm upset because I've
always been arrogant like that it's like
it's like if kojima was just like way
more open about even more so you know
what i mean like like like who she
pretends not to be that weird yes some
extent mm-hmm like kojima was like i'm
extremely cool and yo guitar I was like
oh I'm quirky like I remember another
quote from yo Katara he said something
to the degree of like they asked him
like Oh would you ever make like a
sequel to this and he was like if you
give me money I'll I'll do whatever like
look up any interview with yo guitar he
says some wild [ __ ] it's good
I think someone asked him about like oh
ye are all the characters in Nier
automata like sexy robot girls and he's
like well I just wanted to make
attractive girls in my game I like what
and I was like salute to you my man
wanted to be but to look good yeah and I
guess a sauce out y'all mentioned Hideo
Kojima mm-hmm well I Frank way I've been
playing death stranding on PC because
Cowie assign that to me and I am very
glad because I am one of the people who
absolutely adore death stranding for as
bizarre or as ridiculous as it might get
it's not like it's not that outlandish
when you distill it down to its core
themes and I remember that as I'm
playing this I'm like oh [ __ ] like damn
it it is different - oh my god on PC I
was gonna ask no no no like yes
and during the world.we we've talked
about desk the world yeah forgot about
the world right it was like well before
cannery Tracy well you know that's your
wide yeah that's trending is is it's
it's different now because I we've
talked about it at lengths on this
podcast last year and all that so I
don't want to get too deep into that but
as far as like the PC version goes it's
it's while because I'm playing this I
said this Alessandro and I are playing
it and we're like yo the framerate is
like too damn high like this things
we're so used to playing it on ps4 where
it's like 30 or sub 30fps and it's fine
for that kind of game because you're
mostly you know doing the hiking thing
and going from place to place but here
I'm playing on PC and like this [ __ ]
seems fake it's like too good but yeah
it looks and runs incredibly well
playing ultra wide just being able to
have an excuse to dive back into that
stuff like I'm just walking across grass
as Norman Reedus and like hell yeah this
game sick that game is sick I like I
don't know I think I've been thinking
about it a lot lately partially because
I know it's coming to PC but just how
everyone was like what a weird and wacky
game but it's like not it's not that
weird like a it has like really odd
story beats but overall it's not that
weird I don't know it's got that like
whatever you want to call it like
happily anime or like soap opera II yeah
kind of tone to it and so to me that's
just like a form of like storytelling
choice rather than like like I know
there's a lot of people who thought it
was a really pretentious game and like I
can see that I can see that that's
that's just not how I read it you know I
I read my reading of dust training was
like it's such an earnest lie
heartfelt like here's just this concept
of being good to your fellow human
beings yeah and it's at 460 hours or
however long you play it
yeah it's abstracted in really weird
ways but overall like it's it's pretty
digestible so I really appreciate it
runs really well on PC it uses the
decima engine which is what horizon zero
dawn uses and horizon zero dawn is
actually supposed to come out on PC this
summer so if you're looking forward to
that it's probably gonna run really well
as well I'm really interested to play
because it's that's the game that kind
of I had to skip because my setup at the
time was using a very small TV and there
was a lot of really small text yeah but
now that's coming on a PC changed my
setup a bit kind of explained I'm right
now I'm sitting in front of a 50-inch TV
that is acting as my computer monitor
and my gaming TV and that's about a foot
and a half two feet away from me so when
you mentioned frame rates and ultra-wide
I'm like yeah now I think about not you
mentioned it oh gee that's training on
ps4 there's a lot of small text
especially in menus when you're trying
to navigate the map and read what your
orders are trying to tell you what your
quest objectives are and there's a lot
of I'll I think a lot of neat
storytelling is told through emails and
there's very long emails and it's all
text-based for that respect and I can
definitely see that like having to miss
out on that sort of thing because I I
think there was like a text option for
the ps4 version but I don't know if it
only applies to subtitles or like main
cortex so I don't know if it helped the
menu stuff at all actually came out
afterwards that did increase the that
was just for subtitles or if that was
across the board but I do know that
there were some UI elements that did not
have the font size increase because
that's that's hard to do what the game
is kind of already out there I don't
worry actually the only one that kind of
like actually made that happen because
that was one of those games last year
that also had small text but then one
developer at obsidian basic
within and kind of created a custom font
size setting for it and he's actually he
told me that he essentially did it in an
afternoon but it took three months to be
able to fix all the UI bugs that came
with it
when thankfully obsidian after launch
was able to be like you know what let's
add this in as a patch later on and it
was it basically changed the way that
people can be able to play the game and
it was the first time I actually was
able to jump in and I really enjoyed it
because that's so I it's I know how hard
it is to add in that extra sort of font
size in a game that's already launched
but I think being on PC hopefully like
fingers crossed that they'll add in a
few little extra sort of things to kind
of make it a little bit easier for
people to read the text yeah definitely
or you know at the very least mods might
help with that I wonder if there's mods
for The Witcher 3 speaking of I bet you
sure yeah there are I think I haven't
played around with those specifically I
know there are a lot of really cool
accessibility mods for cuphead which was
something yeah
mods are great I love it yeah yep
Michael was that the last one you wanted
to touch on I have at the time of
recording or by the time this power cut
podcast goes up I will be able to talk
about a exclusive or not exclusive a
Ubisoft game I got to see before
official reveal it's revealed now as
y'all are listening to this but hyper
scape their battle royale FPS so all of
you Kali's jean-luc Steve plug your ears
you don't you don't know nothing I'm
just I saw good I got the reveal like
two weeks before you oh thank you yeah
it's we have so I think Tony and I did a
discussion video and then I did like a
breakdown video and then so I don't
really want to get into it it actually
does some some neat things so you can
check out those videos to get like a
detailed breakdown of all that stuff
mechanics I think it's worth giving a
shot but if you're burnt out on battle
royale get it it's this is for someone
who's looking for more of an arena
shooter style game I think the most
important thing to note is that it's
respawn mechanics are really interesting
but yeah definitely check that out is
free-to-play there's a tech test at the
time of this recording I don't know
exactly how you get into that or if you
can but stay posted if you're interested
because Ubisoft will of course be
talking about that as they inch closer
to I guess
Ubisoft forward or whatever they have
planned for that but I just want to
shout out the gameplay video that we got
coz when so when we we squatted up
everyone squatted up for the it was like
big press event over discord and then I
squatted up with Khalif Adams he's been
on the show blessing a TOA jr. two of my
great friends out and last two guys yeah
they're the best man I love God and
bless
so we squatted up because I hit them up
on this I'm like yo let's take these
fools every time we jumped in the match
we played like 10 matches or like
alright this is a w we're getting W
we're getting the dub right now who's
get her ass whooped bro last the last
match we played before we had to break
out into interviews we're like yo this
is the one all right we got it we got to
do this and I said okay y'all better
y'all better play your a game because
I'm recording this I'm trying to get the
Dove fur for a game spot and I'm YouTube
and [ __ ] cuz I gotta look good but I
trust y'all so we actually got the win
you'll be able to watch that and it has
yeah it has the voiceovers too and just
like bleeps after bleep with the bleeps
it's it's really good it's what's so
funny at the end we were just tripping
balls yo because we were we were
panicking in in many ways because the
way the game works at the very end
there's some neat mechanics there that
really ups the ante in terms of the
intensity and we were just trippin and
when we won were like yo look at us look
at us who thought nah me like
bless and I literally said that in sync
and you could hear it on the video yeah
in Kaunas real w yeah and cause like a
dad to us he's always like commander and
giving us orders and stuff I'm like
alcohol yeah yeah I've played war zone
with Cod he's very much like that
because he was like I was playing with
auntie Renee and we're the three of us
were kind of like like trying to figure
stuff out cause like all right let's go
here we go
yeah commander Kyle right there and I'm
like yo just tell me what to do and I
got you man
so that was that was so much fun man I
love all of those dudes those are my
guys so as of the time this goes up you
can watch all of those videos on our
YouTube and everything I can and I've
written versions all that stuff as well
so that's kind of what I've been playing
this way you've been up to a lot Michael
works constantly thank you define for me
to break man yeah it's it's always so
weird when you work in games and you're
like man I've been working so much and
people kind of look at you like uh-huh
like no I've been in a constant
existential crisis for three weeks
because of my last of us to review
everyone on Twitter is made and I want
to cry oh I'm sure oh we I keep bringing
it blesseth we're not done talking about
what we've been playing Steve it's your
turn so we didn't put in the write down
but it's kind of leaning on in this or
they animated discussion I have been
like its it's animated Jason I I've been
doing my yearly watch of the Matrix
trilogy I'm doing it literally since the
LA well I've been watching The Matrix
pretty much every single year since 1999
and it's literally is my favorite movie
of all time I mean I got those bad boy
as
as basically that's been in my oh it's
Johnny silver ham I've had this for like
almost almost if you're listening to the
audio it's a bust of Keanu Reeves like
the size of your head it's beautiful
mm-hmm I love it
so I've been watching I watched that
quite a bit and because like this time
was like perfect time because everyone
was sort of talking about cyberpunk a
lot and I was like I just need I just
need my Keanu fix
I need my low moments so I was watching
that a lot and then I've also other than
Last of Us I've been playing destiny too
it's one of those games that I didn't
think I was like I was gonna like at
first I didn't actually jump in when it
kind of first came out a funny story is
that in 2018 I had a friend of mine that
I've known for now 15 years and I knew
he loved destiny like he was a streamer
he streams exclusively destiny and I
wanted to jump in and then PlayStation
put destiny to forsaken as it's a free
PS Plus game of the month and I
downloaded it and I asked I was like hey
could you maybe like Sherpa me through
this and kind of help me out and maybe
we can stream this together and he said
well I I absolutely would love to but I
gotta let you know I suck at this as
probably just as much as you do it would
be like the blind leading the block and
I and I said well that's what we're
gonna call it so in early October
shout-out to the 2t Boris he's the T
monster on Twitch him and I every single
like pretty much almost every single
week since October 2018 we've been
getting together and playing destiny to
like and it was it was so cool and I
love the new season better than the old
the previous season because oh god wait
to grindy terrible to slow
I like the only thing I liked about it
was when the almighty fell and yeah yeah
I was like you wait an hour for
five minutes I don't get it my
girlfriend so mad at me cuz I was like
hey they're dropping this thing at like
11 o'clock or whatever it was and I was
like I'm just gonna hop on it'll happen
real quick I'm waiting there for like an
hour and a half and I'm like no no it's
finally starting like you can see the
the missiles are slowly hitting this
thing and she's just like I know you
like this game climatic but I'm like
there's but there's missiles coming from
Mars or from the moon
so and I'm loving this new season
something that I'm really excited for
beyond light in September and yeah I've
just man I play warlock I'm on ps4 and I
don't care what people say warlocks are
great especially it's an accessibility
thing the Warlock jump best jump in the
game and I am actually able to do all
the platforming stuff because of that
jump alone so yeah don't knock be over
like so good I think hunters of the
length of their hunters are getting
hunter not that but I mean y'all didn't
show up for the for the Guardian games
with Titans I mean that was probably
like the lowest point where I just could
not care I was like yeah I was okay with
taking silver I'm fine with that let's
let's take second place so awesome I
guess only really fast I I'm sold but
you know I'm playing a lot of Animal
Crossing still I play every single day
and today I did some absolutely buck
wild
nika's on trades so everybody be really
proud of me mm-hmm I treated 100
macphails tickets for five mushroom
lamps so I can build my enchanted fairy
circle in a forest
that's business wow that's that's
impressive oh yeah so I have now I'm
doing the so what I'm doing right now is
I'm moving all of my rocks into a
circular formation and the way you can
manipulate where rocks spawn is by
understanding how they spawn so you can
break rocks with fruit power this sounds
absolutely ridiculous but you can break
them and then they respawn within a day
and you just have to put items on every
other square of land where a rock could
spawn and occupy that space to force it
to spawn where you want and in my case
in a circular pattern so I can have this
enchanted forest thing going on so I've
started putting down my mannequins and
the reason you use mannequins is because
if you alter the design the mannequins
go away so it's it takes a while to put
them down but there's no cleanup it's
gonna take you like a full week to do I
really sad word that that I've heard
that grinded stuff for hairdressing yeah
I it's I'm excited to do it I love these
long term projects I'm excited to
finally like have an area on my island I
focused a lot of my design on my flyover
I wanted my flyover to be really
impressive when people came to Iowa so I
did that and then now I'm gonna go from
there I kind of had this enchant it's
like waterfall kind of my island theme
is like kind of cottage core but like
kind of like a little bit of magic in it
and related to that my inspiration has
been I've been watching Outlander which
is the twilight of Game of Thrones it is
just it is it's fancy but a romance
novel okay instead of werewolves there's
dragons no there's like it's about a
woman who travels back in time and then
falls in love with a guy in the past and
then so it's it's an it is absolutely an
ace okay so we're back on anime so it's
a nice akai of live-action pieces
about a woman in Scotland she's British
but she's in Scotland she travels back
in time but she has a husband in her
present day which is like 1946 and she
travels back in time and then she meets
this incredibly sexy Scotsman and then
she's like what shall I do and then like
is it cheating if your husband hasn't
been born yet like you know whoa these
are some deep questions it's really
actually a super graphic show like a lot
of sex a lot of like sexual violence
okay that's the game of thrones part a
lot of murderer it's set in the 1740s
and and it's just before there's a
scottish in real life there's like a lot
of like historical [ __ ] going on so like
in real life there was a rebellion
against the British crown and so like
they're preparing for that and she like
knows he'll die so they're like trying
to stop it or whatever
been watching a lot of that it's really
intense the so I'm just kind of like I'm
gonna take the magical fairy selfie [ __ ]
from the show and apply that's my animal
crossing island okay I mean yeah you
watch a lot of trash like you own it too
dude
i watch so much trash I watch I've been
watching 90-day fiance 90-day fiance
before the 90 days ended now we're on
two different versions of 90-day fiance
90-day fiance happily ever after which
is a follow-up season 90-day fiance a
kiwami 90-day fiance the other way where
they move to not the u.s. also love
island much love island every week with
mugger 90-day fiance
royal golden definitive edition
absolutely so welcome to my life
um let's go ahead and wait what before
sorry before we get off I'm here with
Michael Jake's not here prime
opportunity where you at and Sailor Moon
I need to know I'm still in season one I
think - it's like 60 episodes yeah she's
like 60 episodes society we have Sailor
Mars Jupiter weekender no well I'm about
to get to Sailor Jupiter but okay
so yeah real quick sand like [ __ ] you
Jake we're going to UM for the record
Jake upgraded his stance on anime from
no anime to some anime because of the
cyber room the first thing he said to me
the day the cyber fight he liked he
liked it was a Callie have you heard the
news that I had like just woken up and I
was like what he's like triggers making
a cyberpunk anime and I was like you
know what trigger is yeah I you know one
thing I'll say about Sailor Moon is that
it's the most comforting thing to watch
for me it really is it's so delightful
it's yo that [ __ ] is funny as [ __ ] funny
animation he's like okay so like I say
the moon gets like a rep for like
low-budget animation which is like true
because it's like they reuse that [ __ ]
but the actual like drawings are like
really well done like that show looks
beautiful questions for both of you are
you guys watching the sub the table or
the fizz read up the viz redub good cuz
watching this sub because this sub is
read up fixes the kissing cousins drama
yes I've heard it turns them back into
lesbians yeah a shout out to lesbians
you know what I'm saying though you
haven't got there yet I don't know if
you've got there there's a plot thread
that happens right before Jupiter shows
up that is like in 2020 I'm like this is
problematic and weird oh [ __ ] I have you
I haven't gotten there yeah there's a
weird like a girl falls in love with
like a dude who's like probably in
30s and she's like 1450 and I'm like
this is weird
Thanks otherwise I have like a little
PTSD with Sailor Moon because obviously
with the last name of Sailor not spelt
the same way but last name of Sailor
I was called Sailor Moon so much as a
kid I was like yeah and I got like I got
like so mad that I'm like and I'm like
but as an adult I'm like you know what
I've been hearing so much about it I've
been trying to slowly dip my toe into
anime
I just finished Evangelion the first
time not too long ago I mean I love that
and I've been sort of trying to dip my
toe in either avatar full metal guitar
is a perfect television close to perfect
also yeah I just I love avatar it is so
important to me I love it so much
perfect show sales do you think that
[Laughter]
I'll dive in avatar I'll dive in avatar
next we'll have to have you back for
like an anime book club after you've
watched some of those and we can yeah
yeah I am an anime is good it's the it's
good and bad as all things are that's uh
that's a box quote for you the last half
of Evangelion or the last few episodes
kind of proven to me I was like wait why
are we anyway we should probably move on
to some topics we got a really brief one
that we'll start with I know we've been
like totally teasing this last was
conversation but we're first kids talk
about the crisis remaster which was
delayed after a very unfortunate uh it
was a week what what happened
so they leaked the the teaser trailer
which was supposed to come out today at
the time we were recording got today
early by I think Microsoft accident and
everyone looked at it and was like this
just looks like the PC version of crisis
this looks terrible or like not terrible
it just it doesn't look really gamers
did what gamers do and they were really
upset and then they basically were like
wait a couple weeks which I don't really
know what you can do in a couple days
hate this I hate this I will just never
happened before it's so weird
dude there is this one Simpsons code I
think about all the time and it's I
don't even know the exact word for word
quote but Bart is complaining a comic
book guy about something and comic book
guy basically makes us comment like not
ever art like art is it for you like the
creator's don't owe you anything kind of
like [ __ ] and I was just like I think
about that a lot and I wish I knew the
exact quote cuz it's way more funny than
the way I said it but um yeah it's like
the thing is like I do agree with those
people like cuz I watched the trailer
and I was like yeah it's just kind of
looks like crisis like you know in in
this sense that like if you were you're
being pitched a remaster you're being
pitched like it's gonna look amazing
it's gonna you know have all these like
new bells and whistles at least from the
trailer they showed I was like yeah it's
just kinda looks like crisis which is
like whatever to me it's bit like more
like the reaction the fact that they
responded so quickly is like bizarre and
and I'm not even sure what they could
like do you about it and like how could
what are you yeah what are you gonna do
like sweet extra mods a remaster is so
much more than just the game looking
better like maybe it looks similar but
there's there's gonna be under the hood
stuff like it's just right I mean it's
gonna run on on you know modern consoles
they said apparently it's gonna come on
on switch which is like that that's
crazy
like I guess I can understand like if
you're like a PC player who loves crisis
which I guess
you would only be that person because it
never came out in other systems like you
would be a little disappointed of like
oh what's the point like why do I need
to buy this and I would say grow up yeah
I mean I saw I saw like the leaked
trailer as well and like and like to me
I don't know it looked it looked fine to
me I mean then again I don't know if you
want to trust the the word of a blind
guy but I mean it looks fine to me
that's the crisis is credit like that
game still looks really good like good
you could argue they didn't need to do
that much to like modernize it because
they're like look so amazing but yeah
yeah Scrappy's crisis maximum gamers did
you know that was it Crysis warhead dude
this is like peak like like this is it
they called the graphics settings like
like based on like the specs of your PC
so like gamer enthusiasts like gamer is
like hardcore enthusiast was like the
maximum setting name and it's like this
is your fault
like you've created these things by like
doing that you know that right like
you've created your own monsters and
like now they're mad at you and it's
like you did this to yourself by calling
that yes John Mulaney would say I don't
care for that [ __ ] at all anyway let's
move on to the main event because I
think everybody here has been really
excited to talk about this and hopefully
everybody listening is like [ __ ]
finally shut the [ __ ] move on to the
last was part 2 and it's many very
impressive very important accessibility
options so Steve I'll let you can take
it away yeah so again full disclosure I
did consult with Naughty Dog on last was
part 2 in helping to provide feedback
and options and suggestions for some of
the 60 plus accessibility options that
are in this game and to kind of put in
perspective if you're not sort of
familiar with the with what
accessibility has been like in gaming
for the past
years and let we'll use sort of like the
last of us as an example when the first
last of us came out in 2013 there wasn't
really any accessibility options or at
least options that were considered for
accessibility at that time and even in
the gaming sphere like there wasn't
really any game that kind of focused in
on that some had subtitles and some
didn't I'd like to kind of point out
that Assassin's Creed the first one
didn't have subtitles at all and they
didn't have that until two and so that
like that's kind of where the state of
accessibility was at that point and then
jump to now the Last of Us part two and
we're seven years later and we're now
even kind of jumping into a new
generation to see these amount of
options that are available it's like
they set a standard that now all other
studios are gonna have to catch up like
put a perspective essentially in the
ability side this is a moment in time
where we're gonna be talking about
accessibility before the Last of Us part
two and after the Last of Us part two
and there are just so many amazing
settings and if for those who don't
expect there was an oath about the the
reaction video that that I did when I
when I saw the accessibility settings
for the first time I knew going into it
that there was definitely some amazing
accessibility options just from
consulting with it and like I knew is
going to be a game-changer at that point
but it was getting the final final game
and turning it on for a review that I
was doing for can i play that with my
colleague Courtney Craven who was saying
the deaf and hard hearing side where I
was handling the blind side it when I
turned it on at the beginning of the
game you have the option to be able to
turn on three presets there's a blind
and low-vision accessibility presets
there's deaf and hearing accessibility
presets and there are motor
accessibility presets and that is
because there are so many options in
this that no dog was like you know what
we're just gonna instead of you having
to manually turn on every single setting
for this we're just going to give you
here's a preset template of all the
settings and
here's a list of everything it's gonna
turn on and enable and of course at that
point even at the beginning game you
have the option to turn on
text-to-speech so as I was going through
those and looking at all these options I
could hear the Texas speech read out all
the accessibility options in like in my
head and it was seeing that and just
seeing that there was so much there that
like I didn't think that I was gonna cry
and when I recorded it it was originally
gonna be a hike moment for my review
video being like yes this is amazing
let's celebrate the amount of
accessibility options this is so cool
it was gonna be kind of like a get hype
moment but then when I all those
settings were being read out and I was
thinking of all the hard work that we've
been trying to be able to put in for
accessibility for a long time and all
the consultants that I've worked with in
studios I've worked with we've been
trying to figure this out for for quite
awhile and seeing a studio do this so
well I I just started crying and bawling
and I was crying for like a good solid
ten minutes and after that I was like I
can't put this out like there's nothing
I could do with this it sat on my hard
drive for two weeks and until like
literally five minutes before I posted
it I wasn't gonna do anything with it
and I was like you know I'll edit it
it's like a Twitter clip or something
and I was even then I wasn't even gonna
put it out and then I was encouraged by
friends and colleagues and family that
they're like no Steve you got to put
this out and I were very reluctantly
posted it and and I I was afraid of the
I was definitely afraid of the feat of
the feedback because I remember that guy
that got like absolutely ridiculed for
crying over the rise of Skywalker
trailer and I was like I don't like I
don't want that to happen to me like I
seen like how that like how much hate
that can that can conjure and but like
when I as soon as I posted it and it
started to kind of pick up I started
seeing so many people love it and and
comment on it and message me about it
people from Naughty Dog like I even had
Ashley
please Ally I had Troy please Joel I had
Neil druckmann
I even that Hermann Hulst like messaged
me about this and I'm like dude this is
surreal and it just it just it goes to
show like just how important
accessibility is and I will say this it
last of us part to you is the most
accessible game ever it's not the
hundred percent perfect accessible game
because there definitely is a few things
that obviously that they tried to do
that that are not in this in the final
version but hopefully with future
patches they'll be able to add those in
but it's like it but it's as closest
we've ever come to having so many
accessibility options that were able to
like just try stuff at just to see how
things work like my friend Courtney it
can i play that she was mostly working
on like working on from the deaf and
hard of hearing aspect but there was
certain problem that she was having when
when she was trying to use listen mode
and it was hard for her to be able to
kind of know what type of enemies were
in the area and so I suggested hey want
to turn on high contrast mode and
essentially like she did and it allowed
her to kind of like see a little bit
more clearly what it was and like it's
it that's what I love about is that
there's options that even if you'd like
even if you don't have a disability or
if you have a disability that doesn't do
you think of a setting doesn't really
work for you try it and see if it does I
like I can hundred percent like and I
have seen so my friends who even from
The Blind Side like are completely
sightless that could have been able to
complete the entire game
and I think it was even an audio
engineer that no dog had come out on
Twitter and said that you can play this
with your eyes closed or completely
blindfolded and that's how in-depth
accessibility settings are it's it's
incredible the excuse me the the first
thing I did like I don't know what's
happening with my voice the first thing
I did when I duded up the game was look
at the accessibility options and I I had
no idea
going into it I like didn't expect it to
be so
robust I went in because I always enable
subtitles when I play games I watch TV
with subtitles most of the time for me
it is an issue of focus and processing
so it's not like a like an issue that I
have I just find that I like it makes it
makes it more comfy to be able to play
exactly I find that I am absorbing the
story more whatever it is a game TV
movie so I did that and like even the
subtitle options like you can change
like the color of somebody's name so
it's easier to differentiate who's
speaking and you can like on screen you
can have it tell you kind of the
direction of speech and so I was really
impressed with that and I was also
there's a whole motion sickness section
and for me motion sickness my is so
unpredictable and I know people who have
it really severely I have a friend I
tell a story sometimes because like it
blows me away like how much she loved
the original Last of Us and it she
literally just texted me to tell me she
finished last of us part two just now
she dry heaved her way through the last
of us she gets such bad motion sickness
and she wanted to finish it so badly and
I remember I lived with her at the time
and we were like I've heard the story
please take a Dramamine what are you
doing and she's had this problem her
whole life playing 3d games she mostly
plays 2d games or games with fixed
cameras and she she was the first person
they texted about the Last of Us like
when I downloaded it and booted it up I
was like you're not gonna believe this
like you'll actually be able to play
this game without puking like are you
ready like are you ready for this and
for me it's funny that you mention high
contrast mode because I enabled that I
had that setting on for much of the game
because for for two reasons
I found that I would get a little bit
motion sickness well I guess kind of
it's one reason that had two effects I
had a lot of difficulty with the looting
aspect of the game I found you know when
you're just looting maybe it was my TV
but I had a really hard time seeing the
loot
on-like it flashes but I had a really
hard time seeing it and so I would kind
of just like bump into walls and
cabinets and wait for the button prompt
and that's not really an enjoyable way
to play so I enabled high contrast mode
that you can toggle it with the the
touchpad and I it helped so much because
I would just use it to clear rooms when
I was done of the comments on my review
were like you're so stupid you can't
even loop but I was like I it alleviated
the issue I had with looting which is
that it took a long time and because I'm
so thorough and so neurotic I didn't
want to miss anything it helps keep the
pace up of the game and then also
because of my difficulty seeing the
items I would whip the camera around a
lot like clear all my corners in a room
and that made me motion sick so rather
than it changed the motion sickness
options which have to do with like
camera shake and motion blur and stuff I
picked high contrast mode originally I
tried enhanced listen mode but it wasn't
exactly what I wanted in high contrast
mode really was it I just hated the desk
sorry and it it just fixed like it's
such a cool thing because like I don't
have a vision related disability but
that option alleviated a problem I had
with the game and improved my experience
and it's I think it's a testament to the
work that they did on the accessibility
that like it
these are modes that like anyone can
benefit from you don't you don't it's
not jut like accessibility is really for
everyone and I think that actually
helped me come out of the game with a
more positive attitude than some people
and it's been really hard because I feel
like in the discourse around this game
the capital D discourse we've really
lost the conversation about the game's
accessibility and it's like that doesn't
undo people's issues with the game you
can dislike the game story or the combat
or whatever you you didn't like about it
but there's a lot of talk about
different story decisions and Twitter
drama and what's a game review really
supposed to be
and it's like are we not always gonna
ignore the work that was done here
because it's incredible like I wish I
had more space in my review to talk
about it I was like pushing 2,000 words
and I was like I'm kind of on this on
this train of thought and I don't want
to like take a break in my like nuanced
critique of violence to be like a but by
the way did you know you can close your
eyes and play it that's pretty cool yeah
but I was one of those things when I was
reviewing it I was like I really want to
have a separate article about about this
and so hopefully we we we can probably
break this out or use this discussion as
a jumping-off point for that because I
really think it's worth um celebrating
yeah and that's the thing too it's like
even kind of going which what you were
mentioning about it was like difficulty
trying to be able to find items in the
game and yes high contrast mode is 100%
can be totally used for that but there
like there are layers upon layers of
accessibility options and kind of even
add suit like okay like to that
particular issue if you like if you're
like okay you know high contrast mode
just isn't still doing it for me there
are two other options you can turn on
yeah I can mention players audio cues so
if you're completely blind this this is
more kind of for those but it's like
even for me I had it on and it was
absolutely fantastic wear it well
there's an audio glossary that will sort
of let you know what button to push at
certain points if you're interacting
with an item and there's a distinct
sound effect for each individual button
and what's even cooler is that what
proceeds after the those audio cues will
be a sound effect for what you're going
to be interacting with so like you walk
up to a drawer and you you'll hear the
sound effect for triangle and then
you'll hear a sound effect of a drawer
opening and that lets you know okay
that's a drawer and I can be able to
open it but it does that for if you're
climbing a rope I love it actually also
as well like it gives you like a little
whinny whenever you're trying to like
hop on a horse which is so cool but like
so and it also like kind of pings in the
antenna in the room of where certain
items are so that you can be able to
know where to look or lease in what
direction to be look and then even on
top of that as well
there are there's an option to be able
to do auto pickup so if you're just
walking around like unless you have to
like open up something in order to be
able to to find it it'll just like once
it's good to do it it'll just
automatically pick up for you so you're
not having to constantly be hitting
triangle all the time and that's just
that's just how that's just a little
subsection of how subtle and how much
layered these settings can can sort of
interact with each other and work so
well yeah it's it's amazing the audio
glossary was like intimidating I was
checking it out it's like this laundry
list of different cues and like you can
go you can go through it and like get
yourself accustomed to the the sound cue
for each thing
I mean it's and that's just like one
there's like five other menus you can go
into that's just one section if Wilde
did you did either of you Michael or
John Luke like enable anything or mess
around with it at all yeah yeah I it's I
mentioned or you mentioned high contrast
mode not something that I used to
because like Kali which is like spittin
right there when you're saying about how
like because at least in console games
when you have to use a joystick and you
can't really mess with the sensitivity
too much and for me and Kali as well is
that we need to clear out every room
before we move on or otherwise it's
gonna bother the [ __ ] out of us for the
rest of the game even if it was like two
bullets for my pistol or a damn half
bottle of alcohol for crafting it's like
I just don't want to miss anything and I
don't wanna and I don't want to spend so
much time trying to scavenge a room
that's not story critical so I also use
high contrast mode to be like okay let
me make sure that I have everything here
and for like when I play keyboard mouse
it's easy for me to play games like
fallout or Skyrim when I'm when I am
looking for stuff because I can use a
mouse and that's a lot easier for me but
on a controller that I can get like
motion sick or like it'll build up over
time like if I play for two hours and
I'm constantly scouring rooms for stuff
like it's gonna it yeah it definitely it
adds up so being able to use that as a
thing of okay I'm gonna be efficient
the non-critical parts of this game just
so I can not have to worry about that is
was incredible but like like you said
when you boot up the game and the like
you see before you even start here all
your options and I was like to him
this it opened my eyes like I always
like to think that oh I'm I'm conscious
of how the issues that other people have
who aren't like me when it comes to
being able to even enjoy games but when
I saw the menus I was like wow I don't
even I haven't begun to understand the
lengths at which games would need to go
to reach out to such a bigger audience
and in that moment I was like oh [ __ ]
like there this is going to be i opening
for so many people who may have neve
even thought of that before so anna like
when you tell a story about like being
overwhelmed emotionally but i can
imagine what that what that's like man
to free like your entire life of wow i
wish games did this i wish games did
that i love games but i wish games loved
me in that same way and then finally
having this big-ass triple-a title that
everyone so hyped up for to be v like
the shining moment of like what games
can be for accessibility like I
understand that man I I didn't I feel
you on that that is such a such a cool
thing to see unfold and like it warms my
heart to know that a lot of people feel
seeing because of that and it's like
okay and have Naughty Dog that a
first-party Sony exclusive title that
everyone's been hyped up for to be the
example of that is that's strong yeah
and it also in it is well it kind of
gives a roadmap for other studios to be
alike now there's something that
everyone is played and and everyone is
like if even with obviously the sales
numbers so that came out this week the
fastest growing or the fast selling ps4
title or placing it like this is such a
huge deal but also
it gives a roadmap for other studios to
be like okay now we have this example of
like how a game can be made that's that
is accessible as possible and cuz every
Studios been trying to figure it out and
they've like Eve advocates even the
studios I consulted with like there
they're always trying different things
and and they're kind of trying to figure
out a roadmap in a development sort of
roadway to the figure out what to do and
now there's like this example that
Naughty Dog's bass is like hey do this
and hopefully other Studios can follow
suit and copy it oh yeah sets a strong
precedent I would be fascinated if cuz
because you mentioned like the the
distinct audio cues for button presses
you think about how like video games
have sort of like universal verbs for
certain like button presses that just
kind of translate to games overall and
that helps games you know it becomes
more comfortable where it's like I'm I
play a shooter I know a shooters gonna
have this control scheme I would love
this universal language of a game I
can't exactly like I would love to see
if if maybe like we would have those
universal audio cues we're like other
games could maybe like take that and it
becomes a standard where it's like any
game you play you know what the sound is
which means that button and then that
just becomes like a universal thing that
everyone can pick up on because of like
if we standardize that then it just
makes it that much easier to play a game
cuz you don't have to then relearn
certain audio cues every time yeah I
would absolutely love that and if
there's a standard or this the myself or
other kind of accessibility advocates in
the voice we have like can be able to
kind of keep promoting it is that is
that it isn't like accessibility is
important and this will become the norm
and and I hope it's going to become a
topic conversation for for any sort of
major game it related to indie that's
going to come out because I would love
to be able to get to the point when I'm
I'm reviewing a game for accessibility
to nitpick the accessibility settings
instead of just saying why don't you
have some mm-hmm yeah even the language
of it like like calling it accessibility
settings is important the fact that it
it's the first thing you see is like so
important like there's so many times
where you like like rockstar games or
terror
about this we're like it just starts the
game up and you're like no I haven't I
need to go turn on the subtitles like I
and then you're like watching the
opening cutscene without em and you're
like ah this sucks right because like
the fact that they just went out of the
way to have that up front and the fact
that they you know labeled them things
like motion sickness and like you know
like visual impairing like did the
language they use like I think just
helps normalize it and make you feel
very comfortable going through those
settings before you even start the game
and I think that is also like such an
important thing to just like make people
feel like like welcomed to the game as
well sigh it's like when you when you
when you go into someone's house like oh
you good can I get you anything it's
that were like do anything else like and
that's something we've been telling a
lot of developers for years it's like
stop with the cold opens because it's
it's really difficult for jump in and
play when you have to kind of go through
all that and and and I get it it's a
cinematic move to be able to make but
like I correct me if I'm wrong but I
think the uneven the Uncharted series
also can I had like had a few there was
sort of like cold opens but it wasn't
really until I camera if there was like
that but I do remember it specifically
not charred before they had that where
you could be able to change the ground
ability option right off the hop and and
other games I tried to be able to like
to do that as well and we're starting to
kind of see that sort of idea of of the
cold opens like kind of dissipating
still a few that do but I'm glad to see
that that's kind of star to kind of go
by the wayside a little bit mm-hmm and
then something I've been really curious
about especially with regard to playing
the game like with you know only sound
like if you're completely blind is is it
still enjoyable because sometimes
you know accessibility doesn't always
mean not specifically game but doesn't
always mean like it's still going to be
a good experience or like the experience
isn't tails it's still like it's a it's
a band-aid over an experience that is
tailored to someone who can see or
someone who can hear what is your take
on that specifically like how do you
enjoy this story like like it's a pretty
miserable heavy game in a lot of ways
like like how does that mesh with your
feelings about the accessibility so yeah
is that's something even for those like
players without sight it's something
that we've been kind of like generally
whenever majority of times they'll play
with someone that is sighted that can be
able to like sort of explain and kind of
like tell tell them what's what's
happening and that can that can be a bit
of an issue with with this game in
particular there was one option that I
wish they had and regards to that would
make this a completely immersive
experience and I would love if they had
audio descriptions of what's actually
happening in the cinematics and that
would basically make this in extremely
like 100% immersive experience but if
you're if you're playing this game and
and you're only playing via audio you
can still enjoy the story in in all its
all its aspects you may not understand a
certain percentage of what's happening
but you can at least get the the the
main parts of it and the main beats of
that story and you can still feel that
emotion and I think in a way I know a
lot of people sort of discussed of how
violent the game is and how visceral it
the violence is when you're when you're
playing it and I totally get that and I
but you have to also think if there is
an accessibility aspect to that the
reason why that it may it may be so
visceral to you is because of the audio
and the audio engineers design that game
so that it was it still was immersive
for
blind players that they can still like
when you ever hear a rustling blind
players can understand that that's a
coat wrestling or by stabbing someone in
the neck as opposed to the stomach being
able to understand that is is is a key
and an immersive and so I get it it is
very like it's like that's a very hard
thing to hear especially when you hear
like the the death screams of a clicker
even after you've you've killed it I get
it but for someone who is completely
blind like that just makes it makes the
the world feel larger and scarier in a
way because like when you play it
without sound the jump scares don't
really obviously don't affect any like a
blind player it's like wait what what
just happened here like you may hear a
bit of a sound that sort of might scare
you a little bit but having that audio
experience there like even when you go
into an area with infected its if that
audio experience it kind of almost feels
like an audio drama in a way it just
immerses you in and it makes that more
scary and it just hypes that up for you
it's like okay all right I can get
through this I can get through this and
yeah so it's a as someone like who would
be like a completely plain is completely
sightless that's that's kind of why this
game is so important because it's the
first game that kind of really truly did
that yeah I guess I didn't phrase the
question exactly like super well but
that does answer the question of meant
to ask like is it built from the ground
up to be accessible in that way and it
sounds like it is because yes but it's
not it's not like an option on top of a
game that was built without that in mind
it's a game from the beginning was built
to work for all sorts of different
people yes they Naughty Dog did several
things right that we as consults have
been trying to get students to do and
they started it from the start working
accessibility from the very beginning
and that's what we tell constantly is
that you've got a guy starts in the
beginning because you you never know
halfway down the road when something is
it working or it's not you need to be
able to fix it still gives you time in
that development process to be able to
fix it
or come up with a better solution and it
would be part of the tools so that later
on down the road when you're kind of
nearing production and you're kind of
polishing everything up
you're only fixing essentially bugs
within that system instead of trying to
attack all that I like accessibility
stuff on on top of that so Naughty Dog
did that from the very beginning they
also it was a studio wide initiative in
in certain studios you may have one
person or a group of people or even a
small team working on accessibility and
they're the champions of it within a
studio but with Naughty Dog
accessibility was a studio wide
initiative from from Neil druckmann all
the way down they made they made sure
that accessibility was worked on just as
much as the gameplay or the story was
and they really and that rillette care
to detail really shows and also as well
they brought in people like myself at
consultants along the way to provide
feedback and to suggest options and
suggestions for things that the
developers hadn't really thought of
before and they were like yeah we can do
that and we could work on this and that
was like that was really cool they kept
bringing those consultants back and and
saying okay how are we doing here could
what could we be able to do to improve
and they did that through the entire
process and they were also seeking out
other people as well like they sought me
out at a at a conference I was speaking
at on a panel of a blank gamer's at GDC
and I didn't know that there was no dog
developers in the audience and they came
out to me afterwards and said we want to
work with you let's make this happen
okay Dan I was like yeah yeah I'm like
let's make this happen
so I it's by doing those things it kind
of really made accessibility such a huge
part of the process that I'm sure it was
difficult to be able to create
especially with creating there's so many
brand-new options that hadn't been seen
in games before but it takes a team like
Naughty Dog to basically be like no this
is still important and we need to make
make this happen
and I'm so happy with the way that they
that they went about it and it's exactly
what we've been suggesting never
honestly we W yeah like even even subtle
stuff I think I think the game even if
you dunk on the accessibility options
just has quality like subtle quality of
life changes that like improve the
experience like I think the first time
you go to like when you go to a door you
have to like hold triangle to do it yeah
I immediately expected it to be a button
press like urea a tap triangle because I
think that's maybe how the first last of
us did or like games like Uncharted do
it where you actually tap the button to
like open the door and the fact that
they just let you hold it it's like even
as somebody who doesn't necessarily have
an issue with that it's still like I
don't know like after a while like that
just sucks like that sucks on your
thumbs like I think it's just like
realizing that there are like certain
ways that games do things that are like
you know you don't need to do it that
way or can be better for people like is
that because I actually like I have a
friend who isn't in any way I would say
disabled but I remember we played
Resident Evil 5 and we that game has
like a ton of like button presses and
there's that that button press to the
end with the boulder where you have to
like punch the boulder because redfield
punches a boulder yeah play that game
co-op Chris is punching a boulder at the
same time Sheva his partner has to like
climb up like a like a Ledge that she's
about to fall off it is maybe the
hardest button mashing I've ever
experienced in a game and he could not
do it just like physically could not do
it and that game has no ability to like
remove that at all so it's like I think
there are just things and games are like
that just everyone it's just like like
just giving that option for people to
you know improve on or like or just
subtle things you wouldn't think of like
I remember I saw some people make fun of
or kind of like comment on the fact that
um when you beat an enemy encounter
Ellie or you know will always will
always say something like she'll she'll
say a line to say that the enemy
encounter has done and I saw people kind
of making fun of that about how it's
like well that's really obvious and kind
of like yeah but then I'm like but that
also tells people that the enemy
encounter is done and that's very
important the people that need that
confirmation
that is such a good point yeah and not
only that so the even add on top of that
so yes there are those moments where le
will comment like okay that's like now
that's done or that or this rooms done
but there's moments where like your
companion will basically say there's a
gun to the left and it's like I know
exactly there's someone that like has a
weapon that's to my left but even on
even as well and even the audio cues
it's so subtle in how amazing this is
there is a there is an audio cue that
lets you know when you've stealth killed
an enemy when you've killed an enemy
from a range shot or or a gun shot but
then like even as well like not even
just in the combat but there's even a
sound effect that lets you know when
you're going into a cinematic and when
you're coming out of a cinematic so that
you know when to be able to take control
the sticks again like that's how
in-depth this is and and you said it
right it's exactly that the reason why
those lines of dialogue are in there is
a hundred percent for accessibility yeah
and that is just yet another answer to
my poorly phrased question which was
like it was this something that that
came from the ground up and I think that
is is the big takeaway is like
accessibility is not like a patch it's
not it's not you know a layer that you
add on top of the game when you're done
it is something that you you weave into
the design of the game as you as you're
designing it and and as Michael said
earlier like which I really liked was
that you know when you see something
like the Last of Us part twos just just
the most complete excess you know
quote-unquote complete robust whatever
you want to call it explicit
accessibility options you see that you
realize just how much you don't know as
someone who who games are catered to and
I think that's really important for you
know a lot of people in this industry
you know because by nature of what most
video games are there are going to be
certain types of people that are going
to be more prevalent in the gaming
industry because you know some of us you
know being able to afford a console is
something that is you know kind of a
prerequisite right or being
market it to or being able to hold the
controller there's all sorts of steps
along the way you have to meet and
there's a lot that you might not realize
you don't know
and it's really important like seeing
this game made me think a lot about you
know the next time I review a game how
am I going to view the sound design or
the visual design and I had this a
little bit with with Animal Crossing
because I did notice that most things
with sound cubes also have visual cues
except for like one bug there's one bug
you can't catch if you can't hear it and
what like maybe you can't use headphones
maybe you have a hearing impairment but
I it was such a glaring omission to me
because you know like the balloon has a
sound effect and a visual effect the
shadow like there the catching a fish
has a sound effect and a visual effect
so it was a that one I noticed but that
was like the first time I really stopped
to think about it in depth like I wonder
why there's no visual indication for the
mole cricket it's also super annoying I
hate that bug it's really annoying I'm
glad it's out of season bye yeah I just
think I I've been thinking about the
conversation about the Last of Us a lot
because it really haunts me every every
time I review a game I don't know how
all of you feel when when you put your
opinion out into the world but it's a
very vulnerable position to be in
especially if you were positive about
something I think there's you know
there's merit to the conversation that's
being had right now about game reviews
feeling positive
I think there's myriad reasons for that
but I think you know I maybe I sound
like a baby but people are being really
effing mean about it and I know I
hundred percent backed up I've seen that
myself I've been called a corporate
shill
of giving it a positive review or just
even the reaction videos some people
legitimately thought I was paid to make
that video as a marketing gimmick for
the game and I'm like how I don't and
it's and just seeing the hate coming
from it and like of course like getting
tagged in a few was like Twitter
conversations like I kind of I was at
98% of the reactions I had was positive
but right the 2% was coming in from so
many different directions that they just
were like we're so upset I even had
actually it's funny well it's it's also
very mean as well but it was a I laugh
at it because it was a comment I saw
yesterday kind of directed to the
accessibility and someone had said that
they had wished that naughty ugh hadn't
focused on so much on the accessibility
and focused more on story and I was why
hey you don't know how development works
because yes the story people are a
hundred percent working on the high
contrast mode the coda himself you know
like is the only way yeah yeah hundred
percent but it's just seeing that
discourse like I I think it's just from
from people that are just like they deep
the negative discourse is from people
that either a didn't want to get it to
begin with and was already had a
preconceived notion of that they're
gonna hate it so they're just gonna hate
on it for the sake handing out it and
and I truly understand Kali like that
you were but it like your review while I
totally get and it's like a hundred
percent fair and it's and it's not the
the the 10 out of 10 that people were
expecting but that that like that's not
something to to like rail against and
that's not something to basically like
send you so many negative comments and
and toxicity because of it because
that's the whole thing it's that the the
game like you it can forces you to kind
of come up with your own with your own
opinion and you can like it or you
cannot but it's like you you have
you can have like you're okay with
having that on that opinion I just hate
when people sort of force that opinion
on other people yeah and there's this
kind of prevailing attitude in this
discourse moment or whatever that
negative reviews are more nuanced are
better criticism are more like like are
more honest and I've seen games industry
games media people saying stuff like
this I saw I saw a freelancer tweet
before the embargo went up like I can't
wait until the real critics get to
review this game when it's out or
whatever
and I was just like I don't know what
year you're living in but I don't know
like I saw another reviewer another
person who reviewed the game and talk
about all the dad reviewers and all the
dads who loved this game and I'm like I
don't know of a single dad who reviewed
this game I know of like ten women who
reviewed the game like it's not a good
look if any of you are listening to me
which you're definitely not it's not a
good look to act like it's just a bunch
of like stuffy white dads who review
these games like I don't care what site
it is there are there's a ton of people
with different perspectives whose voices
matter and like I don't think it's
arrogant or controversial to say they're
like I think my voice matters on this
game and I just get really frustrated
when people are like all these like
shield reviews that aren't honest and
like be honest with yourself about this
game and it was like well I was look I
liked it I I'm not gonna pretend I
didn't like it just because you think
negative reviews are more sophisticated
and I just think you liked it you didn't
give it a perfect score we just still
liked it yes and like yeah I feel like
I'm in this trap right now I'm totally
just rambling but like the last thing I
want to say is that I feel like I'm in a
trap when I review games if I like the
game then like games media is going to
treat that like a bad review and if I
didn't like the game that I'm gonna get
people like the quartering making videos
about me
[ __ ] best fool her ass like you harass
me on on it to what your he posted it
than my reaction and said all like even
my cynical cold heart is breaking
because like okay great but then I kept
seeing so many comments of just his
community like being so toxic and even
jumping into my replies and being toxic
and I'm like like ya know dude like like
I always I always err on the side of I
want to educate people in regards to it
like if you're negative you're being a
troll I want to educate because again I
get it accessibility something that is
it's something not everyone knows about
and if you're curious about either my
disability or accessibility in general I
have no problem answering those
questions and even jumping into those
conversations even though everyone says
ignore the trolls I will jump in nine
times out of ten and we'll do that but
in this particular case yeah no [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah I I think that like if we really
want to talk about nuance in game
reviews there's room to celebrate the
accessibility while still being critical
of the things that we didn't like
whether you like the game or not you
know in my review I still talked about
the things I didn't like about the game
even though I overall really liked it I
think that like I guess I'm just really
disappointed to see that you know I'm
not seeing as much discussion of the
accessibility like in the Twitter sphere
of people that follow as I would like to
see and so I'm just really happy that we
we got to talk to you about this I know
you've been doing like basically a world
tour with people I know you're on what
could be talk about this and like
obviously it's not the only thing you
can talk about but I really appreciate
you coming to like enlighten us about
what this process was like and give us
more context because I have a greater
appreciation now for what the last was
parts you did for accessibility and and
when you you know you said the beginning
the conversation that like we're gonna
see it as before the Last of Us part to
you and after and I
understand that even more now like it
really is unheard of it's unprecedented
so we should take the time to say hell
yeah about that I think yeah end of my
soapbox hell yeah going for a really
long time and I'm sorry we do have some
questions I think I'm going to skip one
of them just so we can kind of like wrap
up a little bit faster but we do have
one that I just want to talk about
because it stumps all of us think think
really quickly if you have questions you
can email us at after dark podcast at
gamespot.com or you can join our discord
if you want to join the discord you can
email that email address or you can DM
us there's a lot of really awesome
people in the discord I want to shout
out really quickly Daniel Moreno who
made an incredible piece of art in
Unreal Engine 4 I bless my guy shows up
to him with and it's a bar scene and
there's a bunch of different game
symbols and items to see I thought that
was a photograph I didn't think it was a
render Daniel Moreno is I just I I know
you're listening and I just want to say
we had a field day like Jake posted it
and was like there's a bunch of people
represented in this and we all did like
a like image search what's a kolbe like
when you scan the scene yeah we found
ourselves so everybody's going through I
was like I'm monokuma and like Michaels
like I'm the Joker mask and like we're
all finding I love how like me Ben and
Michael like ours could have been like
completely changeable - yeah there's
like mout oh and there's like mod you
bomb like like monokuma might be Ben and
the ash hat might be chastity but it
might be me but it was just a testament
to to how tight everybody is but yeah
anyway that
little advertisement for our discord
crew and this question comes from email
actually not discord this is from Kevin
from West Hartford Connecticut hey after
dark crew if you could replace your
inner voice with any game character who
would you choose and we heard we read
this question we were like huh I feel
like I do this all the time just like
naturally like I'll just I I not with
game characters I do it with like
youtubers I'm watching like if I watch
like if I go on a binge and I watching a
youtuber for a long time their voice
becomes like my inner monologue for like
half a day which is really weird I mean
I didn't fall asleep to markiplier voice
at all Oh
markiplier I want you know it's funny
funny you bring him up like I never I
know of markiplier but I never watch
because I'm not his audience and watch
them play a horror a psychological
horror RPG just because I wanted to know
about the game and it could not get his
damn voice out of my head I was trying
to think of one and like I can't think
of one that's like a specific character
because like some of my favorite games
like I said before were solar league
franchise game so like of course for me
my favorite games were like Star Trek
games so I'm gonna cheat a little bit
and I want Captain Picard's voice in my
head because I just wanted Patrick
Stewart to near me narrate my life as if
he's giving a start like a start a dead
tree did you know that John Luke was
named after uh jean-luc Picard restroom
I'm not French I was gonna ask but I'm
like like I would thought that was a
little too nerdy but I'm like seriously
you're named after Sean the card ya know
I'm not French in any way at all people
like assume I'm french-canadian because
I like grew up like on the border of
like Quebec and like Vermont but no it's
because my parents are like huge Star
Trek nerds and they just really liked
the name so like apparently that like is
so dope I love it
the way my mom tells the story is I
guess they hadn't 100% figured it out
yet but like after I was born the doctor
was like ah have you come up with a name
for him and she just immediately yelled
John Luke and then she like turned to my
dad and said like is that okay he's like
we were his mom so John your mom is
really into Star Wars too when we had
this joke that if like why didn't she
named me after Star Wars and then we
realized hon Luke so that's been pretty
good so it works on many levels but
anyway my answer oh sorry I was gonna
say she's also really into the matrix he
mentioned that earlier she looks your
mom is awesome it's just like Trinity
and she has gone Azhar for Halloween
multiple times yeah neo psyche has a
ring to it my my parents also really
liked Star Trek and I heard my dad I'm
staying with my parents right now I
heard my dad and a work meeting talking
about the Kobayashi Maru and I was like
do you know what you're talking I was I
think seven or eight years old work in
it but well this is turned into a Star
Trek conversation but I will say my
answer is I want Dante Basco be Prince
Zuko Kuya Dante that's my boy oh my god
Dante I've said this before but Dante
Bosco is a an icon in the Filipino
community
shoutout to Dante Bosco [ __ ] I think
it's like 45 still looking young that's
my guy
Dante boss goes on table Wow and he
reacts to tik toks about his voice tick
tock like a song going around tick-tock
that's like someone who sounds like
Dante Basco doing a rap as if he's
Prince Zuko he talks about
breaking guitars back or some [ __ ]
whatever it's about [ __ ] but like the
it sounds like Zuko is doing it and I
watched a video of Dante reacting like
I'm not gay but if I were Dante Bosco
rufio man that's what got me his
tick-tock handle is the same as
everywhere else Rufio Zuko so if you
want to go fall don't have us go under
guys I know a lot of us oh my god like
when even before Avatar he starred in a
movie called the Daboo which in my
community since we're like a majority
Filipino for us it was it was in feeders
and it was a Filipino movie in theatres
starring Dante Bosco in joy Briscoe
who's a cousin of someone that we know
from San Diego
she's like a mutual cousin of a mutual
friend and it was just like this wild
experience of like being 12 years old
I'm like what like there's a a Filipino
movie in theaters at the foot and so
from that point on we stand on say Bosco
that's my guy hmm so sorry Kevin that
isn't from a video game but I think
we're all in agreement yeah my answer is
uh sans my answer would be Keith David
Besson what is he doing like Anderson or
is he doing like he's doing all of it
man Keith David has like one one like
tone and it works for every single thing
that he does
including my inner monologue he's a he's
captain Anderson in Mass Effect he he
plays himself in Saints Row 4 row which
is really good he's his child's and the
thing is also in an ATL the movie with
ti that I watched when I was 15 and it's
awesome I loved oh yeah oh my god that's
that's really people who stand keep
David man
I love that man um let's see this one I
think I just want to shout it out cuz I
don't think we have time to really talk
about it in depth but I do want to
address it this is from Joshua Jones
from Modesto California hey night crew
just a test of a nickname for the host
of the podcasts I like it I like night
crew while playing The Last of Us part
two I ran into an audio dialogue glitch
guessing near the end of the game where
the subtitles are showing but no audio
from the characters music is clearly
playing safe before the glitch so I can
hope for a patch for the game had a
similar glitch in spider-man first he'll
see where a whole cutscene was glitched
and acted like he was played when it
didn't just wondering if any one of the
crew has had technical glitches for this
generation of consoles glitches that
don't break the game but break your
heart halt thanks for reading this PS I
found manga and anime stuff on books in
the last of his part 2 there's yeah
there's a character who likes anime oh
yeah like Jake's like who's Pearl Jam's
like did you hear the guy say anime
because now you can't like this game is
it Jesse
no it's not Jesse damn Manny Manny who's
great III had a horrible glitch in Last
of Us 2 actually the game crashed at the
very end during a very pivotal moment of
the game it crashed and we were just
like what happens we're like oh my god
you probably know I mean there could be
multiple but like it was right near the
end and we're like oh my god I might and
but the funniest thing is I was talking
to my friend like a day after cuz he had
just beaten we were talking about it and
he would he apparently had it crashed in
the exact same spot and I was like oh my
god so Naughty Dog's listening maybe you
need to fix that because might have not
just been us and that is a heartbreaking
place to have that happen I mean that's
the thing like gays are so complicated
there's gonna be like weird there's just
gonna be weird things that you can't
are you okay I can't even get mad
anymore like if there's a good job
welcome like a [ __ ] man like I feel bad
like ha I couldn't do better I'm sorry
like like of course I see a lot of
glitches and bugs all the time
especially when I'm consulting cuz it's
like okay it's like it's not even fully
made yet but I will say there's there's
one story it's not in regards to this
previous gender but it's also like it's
a fun like I don't know if there was an
Easter egg but it was a glitch that I
turned out to be something really cool
so no of anyone here or anyone listening
has ever played the matrix online no but
I again back to my love of the matrix of
course I jumped into that in the beta
and I absolutely loved it but it was
actually a radio station that was a part
of in that at that point which was
really really cool but we found actually
it was a bunch of us DJs in the station
it was called ready for his ion we also
we found out about this glitch that we
it sort of took you into a spot in the
matrix that you wouldn't think like you
wouldn't have been able to know about
but you know from watching the movies
and we had to go into this really weird
spot in the in the megacity and like
India to go downtown have to go into
this basement and kind of go through
this specific wall and you have to kind
of jump down a little bit as if you're
kind of like jumping through like down
some stairs and essentially you kind of
like you go underneath the world and
then you have to basically kind of like
matrix fly your way underneath until you
find this from this really large box
that like you just don't know what it is
until you fly in and all of a sudden
you're in the infinite hallway of doors
from the matrix equals and I love that
so much I took so many like screenshots
and videos that I only have one video
left of this day the rest I lost but it
was it was like one of those things like
I don't know if that was intentional to
feel there like had to go through all
those hoops to say that's right yeah but
it was it was like it was a kind of one
of those glitches that turned out
amazingly well that's that's a beautiful
story I look that's way better than like
the game crashed I was gonna say I did
experience one in the last was part two
where I opened a cabinet and then
Ellie's arm got stuck like this and kept
doing this like horrifying like yeah
yeah like stretched out words I can't
say like this because it's people are
gonna listen to the audio it was
stretched out words as if she was
opening a cabinet but then it didn't
return to her side and they just
reloading the last autosave fixed it
wasn't a big deal but Alessandra filari
on of GameSpot called me because he
encountered a glitch where it's a
fistfight you do kind of like halfway
through the game with a very like large
enemy human enemy and like he was like
it's not letting me punch he called me
he called me he was like please tell me
I don't have to restart am I supposed to
not be able to punch like I'm really
sorry I think you're gonna have to look
so I told it like he had tried reloading
and restarting the game and I was like
why don't you try going into the menu
like the story select or chapter select
menu and then loading in from like a
it's sort of fresh it takes like the
last time you encountered that chapter
and completing it like has your the ammo
you had so you're not gonna like lose
like oh I had all this ammo and now I
have nothing
so like try that and that's what worked
but he was just like I don't want to
start that's the that was another one
that turned out happy but but not as
good as as the matrix one that that's
yeah that's not here and then I
unfortunately I don't think I have time
for the last question but I do you want
to do a shout out to depressed depressed
carbon wow I really butchered that
depressed a carbon thank you for the
question I'm sorry we don't have time to
get to it today hopefully we have time I
own
another show and I like your name and
then finally a shout-out to splat Tim
who actually gave us a shy Oh shite oh
hold another meeting to splat Tim I got
this I do need another drink
shout out Michael what Tim says quick
shout out to Michael I mean Callie loved
and appreciated your answers to my music
questions last week on the pod I enjoyed
listening to the whole discussion but
y'all really brought it yeah the music
and P Phi royal undertale and sine are
wild hearts for days so I just wanted to
acknowledge SWAT team there yeah any any
final thoughts you guys we've been going
for a while I'm very sorry to so much
fun but at the same equal Lee
enlightening I got learned so much I've
had such a fun time talking all kinds of
[ __ ] but also substantial stuff so
this is top tier s tier episode of
GameSpot after dark you know what it is
when you wash it when you watch or
listen to this episode man damn so as
always we're gonna do the where can we
find you and plug section the podcasts
we'll start with Steve our guest of
honor
where can people find you on Twitter
website obviously we talked about can i
play that and do you have anything you
want to shout out anything you're
working on yeah so you can you want to
follow me on Twitter I'm at Steve Saylor
si y lor although I did years ago claim
the regular spelling of it and say this
is not this new sale you're looking for
and think so yeah Steve Saylor on
Twitter or my youtube channel
youtube.com slash snowball yes I've had
that is my actually rounding up in
YouTube in like November 2005 so I've
had it for like 15 years that used to be
my nickname back back in the day and
yes you can go to can i play that calm
where we have amazing reviews for video
games from an accessibility standpoint
we have a ton of Last of Us coverage if
you want to really do a deep dive into
accessibility we had some interviews
with some of the developers at Naughty
Dog we had interviews with all the
consultants that worked on the game as
well and we have even some thoughts on
some of the some stuff for motor
disabilities where our mobile editor
grant Stone or he actually can't play
the game because he has trouble trying
to be able to hold a DualShock
controller so he's trying to figure out
a hack
by using trying to figure out a way to
be able to use the xbox adaptive
controller by connecting it to a
Playstation so he's trying to figure out
if he can either do that so keep an eye
on can I play that for that but as far
as even on my own YouTube channel
actually I'd literally just finished a
video that would go up it'll definitely
be up by the time this episode airs
where I do a deep dive into possible
accessibility in cyberpunk 2077 based on
some the gameplay that we've seen
already and I have some concerns and I
have some hopes for the game so if you
want to check that out like I said
youtube.com slash snowball or it'll also
be on can i play that calm as well
awesome
John Luke what about you I'm working on
some cool stuff with Jake about
cyberpunk related if you like cool lore
videos that like dive into that world
we're trying to get like build up some
hype around that game and there's
there's so much to dive into because
there's like 40 billion rule books for
that game that I've been like slowly
reading the last couple weeks which is
like a lot of fun yes absolutely
I'm down and then on hopefully me and
Ben will have something cool next week
on a game that's coming out the other
one that if you know me and Ben you know
like oh you will hopefully be doing
something around that I mean we got like
I was like I'm gonna I have to I have to
do something around it so I'm hope for
that
yes well we have been like just what a
tease that's the whole episode is just
how do we string people along until we
get to the thing that everybody wants
just keep doing that until Oh John we
thank you Jake always forgets to uh
Michael oh damn you know you can find me
and all the mob [ __ ] at Michael P hi
I'm on Twitter I this week is been wild
I'm going to have coverage of C no Alice
which I just talked about I have full
interview with some of the developers
and yah guitarra himself and all of his
wild answers des [ __ ] PC coverage we
got that up hyper scape coverage you saw
a battle royale game some play for all
stuff as well and also for to celebrate
the fourth of July I am going to have my
day sex 20th anniversary feature in
which I talk about how it is a takedown
of capitalism and I'd Steve I wanted to
ask you if you know about Deus Ex at all
because if you love for the matrix and
how there's so many girls okay yes but
yeah I'm that is that something I've
been working on I've been chipping away
at because it's it's pretty heavy as is
so I want to like take a step back and
make sure I'm not like Wilin out but
Deus Ex definitely means a lot to me
it's one of my favorite games of all
time one of the most influential games
I've ever played and it is more relevant
now than it has ever been especially as
an adult who is experiencing the world
as it is today so peep that and the
weekend it's we I so I don't have a
whole lot that I'm working on I'm
actually just really looking forward to
reading all of this stuff and watching
I am super intrigued about how the
adaptive controller might work on on ps4
because works yeah but yeah I I guess
the one thing I'm working on is in the
animal crossing update is going live
it'll be live by the time you listen to
this podcast so I'm going to be checking
that up probably try not to work over
the weekend as it is a holiday weekend
but maybe Monday or something I'll have
some thoughts about swimming and animal
crossing real hard-hitting stuff over at
my desk you can follow me on twitter at
inky GOI n KY do ji k ko I can't change
it because the having a verification
badge really protects me from a lot of
mean comments so I'm sorry about my
Twitter handle as always thank you for
listening we love you all thank you
again Steve for coming by the podcast
not me I mean you'd have to go anywhere
but thanks for joining our zoom call and
pleasure just to join in here on that
note we will say goodbye next week peace
[Music]